in all three of these cases these folks
had the problem they had experience and
in hindsight there was an obvious
opportunity to make something 10x better
but
most people thought they were idiots and
that's probably the overarching theme
they had to be contrarian
hey this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell today we're going to talk about
where do great startup ideas come from
we've picked three successful yc
companies to unpack this question airbnb
coinbase and stripe and there are three
common themes that we've seen through
all three of these companies the first
timing was important
for each of these companies there was a
pre-existing product
pre-existing competitor dominant you
might say but there was an opportunity
to make something that was 10x better
than what existed
number two
most people founders and investors
thought these ideas were horrible
either because they were too hard to
execute or because they just were bad
ideas
and then number three and i think the
coolest one of them
is that each of these opportunities
turned out to be bigger than the
founders even knew when they started
they turned out to be way bigger
all right
so let's talk about airbnb um
one of the things that i think is really
interesting to set this up is that
existing products did exist right airbnb
did not come up with this idea so what
were you using before airbnb to airbnb
dalton yeah um
for context i i think if you if you've
only seen airbnb you think they came up
with the idea that's probably if i if i
talk to my mom she'd say oh airbnb is a
great idea that those founders dreamed
up um but back in the day i was already
using vrbo
before airbnb was even funded by yc or
or existed there was also a very popular
startup called couchsurfing which was
quite similar to airbnb and it had a lot
of mind share
had a lot of it was a big network and so
it kind of felt like
the third-rate entrant
to a crowded space at the time i
remember when they were nyc that was my
perspective do you remember that michael
how'd you use any of those because i'd
use vrbo personally and i thought i had
used vrbo i had also used couchsurfing
um
one of the reasons why i was actually
excited about working with the airbnb
folks was because using couchsurfing was
so painful
and so
i think that you know first thing when
it comes to timing i think they nailed
this hardcore they weren't first
but the existing products weren't great
and i think it's interesting to talk
about why the existing products weren't
great because
honestly
that's important i would argue that like
there were two fundamental facts that
made the existing products not good
the first is that vrbo and craigslist
did not facilitate payments
so when you arranged in
a house share with someone or staying in
someone's apartment you still had to pay
them either in cash or check or wire
and there was a lot of friction because
there's two people who don't know each
other having to trust each other to
transmit payments
i think the second problem that vrbo had
was they charge hosts to list
and if you think about the core insight
of this market it's that hosts are the
game if you can get the most hosts you
win you have the best inventory but if
you charge them up run to be on your
site uh like you're probably doing it
wrong
so to me
timing was huge existing product did not
there were 10x improvements that can be
made and the second thing that was
really interesting was that um
they were solving their own problem
like most people don't realize that
airbnb started because
joe and nate needed to make rent money
and there was a big conference going on
in san francisco and they basically
rented out room on their floor
to host people so that they could make
some money
and it's funny because we always talk
about personal problems but like
not being able to pay rent that's like
that's a real problem right
and that doesn't sound like a vacation
rental which was what i was used to
seeing uh on vrbo which was vacation
rentals exactly exactly i think it was
interesting at the time that a lot of
people realized that they could use
their property to make extra money and
it's not a coincidence that this
happened around the same time as the oa
crash where a lot of people needed to
make an extra buck and suddenly they
realized oh i have an asset right now i
can make some money on then i think the
last thing is
they used their own product airbnb
didn't realize the insight around
facilitating payments around accepting
payment when they launched
they didn't have an insight when they
launched you know brian came and spoke
to yc recently and he shared the story
that when he used his own product and he
forgot to bring money for payment
and the host thought he was a fraud
he realized oh crap like our site needs
to allow people to pay like we have to
solve this problem
so
it's funny because these insights seems
obvious
now but dalton back in the day you know
put your investor hat on what were the
[ __ ] takes like why did everyone think
oh this is a dumb this is dumb oh look
there's two extremes one was
renting a house when someone is already
home renting a room in a house with a
hoster there
was like the ultimate unappealing scary
bad thing that no one wanted to do
especially
older folks you know like investor folks
like investor types
you know you have a lot of money and can
afford nice hotels you want to go stay
in a stranger's apartment in manhattan
like no thank you right so it was
extremely unappealing idea of people
worried about
those sorts of things
um
and then like the other
the other insight i have for you on this
one is
it was seen as uncool and impure
when you're building the community at
this time in history to charge money for
it
like the couchsurfing ethos was it was a
very like communal
community based pay it forward
social collective action
decentralized goodness
thing
and to be commercial
was extremely in poor taste and remember
michael you and i both were the founders
of this era
all of the messaging that was bombarded
from us from everyone all of our peers
is that making money isn't cool and
being commercial isn't cool and what
they should have done
is get as big as they could and and get
100 million people on airbnb and then
charge once they built the network and
so to charge
that's a horrible idea guys build a
network first and then charge right like
again you went through this as a founder
man isn't this what
you would have been told
it's it's what we were told i mean
twitch became big
when we started diversifying our
business model and it started accepting
direct payments from users in addition
to
ads but that was seen as
dumb back then
so
clearly and of course this is going to
be a common theme if they had listened
to most of the investors
or most of the founders at the time
airbnb wouldn't exist yeah it'd be like
well couchsurfing is free so your plan
is to build something like couchsurfing
but with no users and you're just
starting and you're going to charge
money for it good luck that sounds like
a suicide mission
right all right so so the next one is
coinbase so set the scene for coinbase
what do you think brian saw when he was
getting rolling
yeah so i was around
back then and i was trying to buy
bitcoin back then too and i remember um
the coinbase yc application really well
in the whole historical context so to
set this up for people
circa 2011
2012 it was really hard to buy bitcoin
really hard i remember looking into it
around 2011 and there was a step of
sending money orders like going to
western union and sending a money order
to some foreign country and that's when
i opted out of it i wish i would have
done it would have made a lot of money
but i didn't because it just seemed too
much like a total scam like if you ever
sending money orders to foreign
countries something is going wrong in
your life right um but anyway
i also um was familiar with mountain gox
and mount gox was a was the biggest and
largest bitcoin exchange back in the day
and um
it went down a lot and got hacked and
everyone lost all their money i actually
lost some money at mount cox personally
um i think i had about one bitcoin in
mount cox
i'm not too worried about it um i feel
like the reputation for mount gox was
like you can get money in
but you can't ever get any money back
out
that was the environment where
is that
was an acronym that was magic that
gathering online online exchange it was
originally a website to trade magic
cards that they pivoted into into
bitcoin and so anyway
um the historical insight was buying
bitcoin was something people wanted to
do
but all of the options were pretty bad
that's the historical context and brian
wanted to fix that
i think what's really
interesting about this is we come back
towards he wasn't the first mover
was not the first mover but the product
that existed was so bad that a 10x
better product was actually within reach
like it was actually possible i think
the other fun insight here is that like
portable online gold
is valuable like it is 10x better than
gold
and so as something you might want to
have
if you think gold is something that you
might want to own and it seems like the
market does like owning gold portable
online gold
strictly better
so i think
out of maybe all three of these founders
brian
was exposed to the most [ __ ] takes the
most
people saying this was not gonna work so
break that down first like explain all
the reasons why coinbase is not supposed
to work and brian should not be a
successful founder today
well at the time um
people saw bitcoin as a tiny market that
it was going to crash that it was a
bubble um investor didn't like it it was
synonymous with a lot of you know actual
fraud right didn't didn't have a great
reputation
also getting a bank deal was impossible
it's not like other founders didn't want
to start something like coinbase uh
us-based exchanges were incredibly hard
to start and this is the reason why all
the exchanges at the time were offshore
was uh the regulatory environments were
different in different places right
another thing i want to note is even
brian in his yc application
didn't really believe
in his own idea because what he
basically applied to yc with was um
the p2p transfer parts it wasn't buying
bitcoin and holding it it was the idea
that he could build something like
paypal to do p2p transfers and that the
the buying bitcoin part but that was
just part of it and so isn't it funny
that
even he
kind of under accounted
the simple promise of buying bitcoin in
a non-sketchy way with a debit card in
the us
and not getting hacked and losing all
your money
that was enough that was enough of an
insight to be the basis for like a
hundred billion dollar company he didn't
need to do all this other stuff
but
and following the pattern
a valuable insight that he learns after
starting the company right like you
don't have to have all the valuable
insights before you start
well you remember what the coinbase
product was back in the day right it was
a website
you logged in
you put in how much bitcoin you wanted
to buy
and you push the button and you bought
it and that that was you could sell it
too there was no there was no social
network there was no comment fee you
know it was probably
the simplest products
there were no graphs
it was one of the simplest products i've
ever seen
yeah
but it's because it solved the right
some single problem at the time
and and i think that the way that this
is kind of embodied was that
uh fully embodied how bad of an idea
people thought this was is that he had a
impossible time raising money on demo
day
and so if he had taken the demo day
signal the investor signal of oh we
don't want to give you money
and quit
we don't have coinbase
correct
all right last one
stripe
so um
you had dabbled with payments
um pre-stripe how easy was it
to accept credit cards online
pre-striped tell yeah share the story
with everyone i have set up before
stripe existed i set up um accepting
credit cards from for my companies twice
once in
2002 or so believe it or not when i was
very young and then once again um
in 2007 and to get a merchant credit
card account um
was like applying for a mortgage you had
to fill out lots of paper
you had to fax in stuff you had to
personally guarantee things they had to
do fraud checks on you
it was rough it was expensive there was
minimums and so it's a possible thing to
do
but i would call it gnarly and
the opposite of easy in every way okay
and so that was so and i also remember
when strike came out i was actually in
the strike beta i was one of the first
hundred customers of strike way back in
the day for my cup for my third company
the third time i want to accept credit
cards and um
i really wanted it
in terms of make something people want
when it came out
and i read about it on hacker news i
immediately wanted strike
and i hadn't even seen it yet i just
knew i wanted it
so that that's a historical context
you know it's funny we were
authorized.net users too um at justintv
and twitch and
perfect example again of like a taste of
the good stuff but so hard to you it
took us three months to start accepting
credit cards i think there was a 30-page
contract that we had to read and figure
out a sign and it was like wow so once
again not first mover
i think another really interesting thing
about stripe was that
it was a problem that they saw their
peers in yc have
so literally they were seeing all of
their friends in yc not like going
through all of the pain of
authorized.net and they were hearing
this story over and over again
and then you know that's a good hint for
people out there looking for ideas like
if all of your smart technical friends
are complaining about the same thing
maybe
it's a real problem
now last insight that i think that they
had
talk to me about
their go to market and specifically
about
understanding that their customers were
developers and not business guys because
i think that was revolutionary at the
time
yeah the the really clever
brand promise or marketing stance or
whatever you want to call it they had
was to try to make the most beautiful
website they could with the most
beautiful documentation
that was every you know programmers
dream like they they constantly ask
themselves and push themselves to say
what would i want or what would it what
would a programmer want and this is so
different than every other
processing company because it was built
for basically business people like the
customer was not the the programmer who
had to implement authorize.net was not
the customer it was like some
someone getting paid you know 20 bucks
an hour or something to
to implement the code whereas this was
like they went nuts
at making something that developers
would just freak out about and everyone
copied it by the way every developer
would copy the stripe documentation copy
the stripe website it was like
the apple it was it was like if steve
jobs had to design
a payments
company it would be stripe and i think
they totally did this on purpose but
what this created is a lot of
buzz on hacker news and around nerds
basically that
hey have you seen the stripe thing oh
are you in the band also they did a beta
invite program
and so there was a it was a hot
commodity to be able to get into stripe
and be able to use it you were seen
as well connected if you got the the
pleasure of getting to use stripe it was
like a favor they were doing you to use
their product that's how that's how
that's what a great job they did in
making the website and documentation
excellent
what i love is that when the
strikefounders came to speak at yc the
other detail they added was it was the
most expensive product in the market
like to make sure people really wanted
it they didn't give it away for free
they didn't price it comparably they
made it more expensive and people were
still desperate to use it like that's
how you know you have an insight like
when you're the most expensive thing
speaking of apple and people still are
desperate for it now the [ __ ] takes
right the [ __ ] takes were pretty clear
one what are two teenagers doing in the
banking space the right government
regulation it's the most regulated space
in the [ __ ] world right isn't this
like a suicide mission you're like hi
we're 19. um
we want to start basically a bank
give us all your money like we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna handle hundreds
of millions of dollars of everyone's
money so yeah that's our plan and there
will be no fraud like we're good
i think the second one is that
even subtracting the regulation they
needed a bank deal they needed wells
fargo to let them start using their
rails well like as an early stage
startup they need to get that which at
the time seemed impossible
and then of course i think the last one
is that like
you know paypal existed there was a
really popular company where it felt
like paypal was like a quarter step away
from this right and it was like oh
even if you start doing well paypal can
go here instantly they have all these
users they're the hot company
yeah it was seen as a crowded market
with huge companies with hundreds of
employees thousands of employees and
it's the classic thing again the knock
against yc companies at the time is why
c would just fund
crappy versions of existing company like
the third-rate knock-off version of
something actually good was what yc
companies were isn't that hilarious i
don't know if people remember that but
that was the reputation of yc companies
is like oh yeah
they'll take a existing idea that's good
and they'll make like a less popular
version of it which which kills me
because like
in all three of these cases these folks
had the problem they had experience and
in hindsight there was an obvious
opportunity to make something 10x better
but
most people thought they were idiots and
that's probably the overarching theme
they had to be contrarian
to walk down this path because if they
had asked
10 startup experts 10 investors 10
fellow founders eight of them would have
told them that they were stupid
and like they had to build good products
like you can't take for granted you
can't we can't you know talk on a
whiteboard and plan our strategy and win
all of these founders had to actually do
it and the doing it part was the hard
part
yes
right like all these people had to
execute and build a product that people
loved and actually worked and all these
people built products that handled
hundreds of millions of dollars and they
couldn't lose the money
right so the actual execution bits
talk is cheap execution's hard
execution's expensive they all these
folks had to execute
so i think what the takeaway here is
if we can sum this up
one you shouldn't give a [ __ ] if there's
an existing product in the market
if you're a user of that product or your
friends or users of that product and
they all hate it and you should not give
a [ __ ]
um two
you should not give a [ __ ] if most of
the people around you who you believe
are experts
don't think this is a good idea
especially you shouldn't care if they're
not going to be users if they have no
experience with the pain of using the
existing product and then three
be very careful about your initial
market math be very careful about
pretending that you know how big the
market could be it turns out with so
many of these transformational
technologies there are use cases you
can't dream of that once you build a 10x
better product other people will do
and so
each and every time these founders were
presenting oh we have a market size of
blank the next time they raised money
they could say actually we made a
mistake the market size is actually
bigger we didn't think of this we didn't
think of that and so don't be
discouraged if someone's like that's a
tiny market that's kind of a [ __ ]
um thing that would have killed all
these companies
all right talk to you later man